c'est la guerre il ya des règlements de
comptes entre les miss globalement il ya
deux clans les geneviève de fontenay et
celles qui sont hospitaliers étaient
tout a éclaté sur le groupe whatsapp sur
lequel les mises communique avec sylvie
tellier ya un gros poids de sapouy
sachets de thé spectateurs où il ya
toutes les miss
voilà si on arrive à rentrer dans ce
qu'on pourra faire il a dû fermer l'eau
il doit terminer
c'est la première mauvaise nouvelle aux
gens des week-ends il a parlé et donc
sur ce groupe whatsapp elles se sont
déchirés cas ce que leur certaines ont
été boycottées mise à l'écart du fameux
livre descente en demis alors il ya eu
un livre descente en libye parions
rachel vous n'êtes pas dedans pourquoi
j'y suis mais brièvement cet opus est le
record d'audience à bruxelles par me
change ou des vous êtes le record
d'audience mois après on sent cette
journée d'investisseurs je ne vais pas
déclenché de guerre
non mais je dirais qu on veut pas de
guerre on veut juste la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité je le jure
vois d'ici en fait d'ailleurs j'avais
pas lu le bouquin et c'est ma communauté
instagram qui a vu bouquins et tous et
qui me dit non mais c'est quand même
dingue n'était pas dedans donc un
message de messages trois messages dit
c'est bizarre donc je vais jeter un oeil
sur le bouquin et là c'est vrai que j'ai
une petite photo en avec d'autres miss
régionales donc pas du tout
représentatif en tout cas de mon
couronnement et du coup ça m'a fait un
petit pincement au coeur j'avoue mais
parce que pour moi en fait j'avais
l'impression que mon année elle avait
été une année blanche et que j'avais pas
existé c'est alors que pour moi mais
france ça a bouleversé ma vie sa flore
sa chance cela fait toujours partie de
ma vie aujourd'hui parce que je resterai
toujours miss france et je renierai
jamais ce titre parce que ça aujourd'hui
voilà ça m'a apporté énormément de
choses comme vous avez été miss miss
merguez donc à prévoir
là j'avais oublié aucun problème avec
sylvie tellier
parce que tout le monde dit que sylvie
tellier il ya un problème avec l gilles
verdez rachel est ce que vous êtes de
quel côté vous même pas un côté
geneviève de fontenay sylvie je pense
pas que ça soit ça en fait c'est on est
dans une tranche entre 2003 et 2010 ou
en fait on lui sert pas beaucoup à 6 lui
d'accord en fait c'est la présidente du
comité miss france
alors oui cette après midi on a eu au
téléphone robert se basse cela faisait
plus de vingt ans qu'il au fessier à la
direction du commun
des muses guyane sauf qu'il a été viré
il ya quelques semaines par sylvie
tellier
la raison est la suivante il a aussi
alerté sylvie tellier sur les dangers de
maintenir l'élection malgré la qu'ovide
il est désabusé
je vous propose d'écouter son témoignage
ccravh c'est quelqu'un que j'ai
découvert mois à la suite de madame de
montespan temps qu'il aurait été censuré
à mesure que quelqu'un prendre de
l'assurance à ce que bagarre mais
sûrement monter en grade pour sur la
chaussée pour la société par rapport à
la portée d'un clic sur la guyane
je vous ai pas demandé c'est pour toutes
questions avant d'avoir mal
la pandémie cas qui arrivait à les
occuper les choses que tu prendras
incroyable agile c'est un management de
sylvie tellier très dur si vous n'êtes
pas avec elle elle vous vire tout
simplement donc lui s'est élevé contre
la pandémie il y en a d'autres à l'euro
en main tous les comités ça va très fort
et vous rachel quand même j'ai un
message de vous sur le groupe whatsapp
où vous dites j'ai été blessé oui vous
avez été blessé c'est très dur pour vous
ne pas avoir été dans le livre en fait
c'est dans six mois je
d'un point de vue humain oui même par
rapport à ce qu a pas que moi il ya
d'autres miss france clients ont été
très peu représentées voire pas du tout
représentés et je pense qu'elles ont
ressenti exactement la même chose parce
que le livre ça restera la bible entre
guillemets c'est long plus c'est
officiel et c'est celle est censé ne pas
être dedans mal on se dit qu'en football
pour moi la civi a dit qu'elle aurait dû
faire un album panini